[Music]
[Music]
all right people
this is it i'm live on the youtube for
the last time in at least a month
it's been a while since i've gone live
but we are live on the internet
and i am about to go off the grid that
is right
i will not have a phone i will not have
a computer i will not have a laptop i
will not have an ipad or an ipod
i will not have a uh what else connects
you to the internet any of those
devices i will not have any screens of
any kind
i will not have any news of any kind i
will not have any current events
of any kind i will have absolutely
nothing
electronic no nothing for one month
starting at midnight tonight officially
although really when this stream ends
i'm going to send out one little twitter
thread and then i've got a bunch of work
i got to finish up with my team over
here
and then that's it i am going to
disconnect i am going to let the brain
reset
i am going to relax i'm going to work on
eating right i'm going to work on
fitness i'm going to work on relaxing
i'm going to catch up on reading which i
have not been able
to get much done uh for the last couple
months because it's so busy
uh and i'm just going to kind of live
like it's 1985.
remember that 1985 it was it was a
pretty good year back to the future came
out in 1985
i believe um i have done this
now for three years so this will be the
fourth august that i did it
and each year it's funny when i did it
the first time it was just kind of like
a lark i was just like ah let me just
see if i can do this seems like a kind
of fun thing to do everyone's kind of
nutty because of the internet i'm always
staring at my phone we're all distracted
our
attention spans are short or i think
it's screwing with people's short-term
memory
we're slammed with nonsense all day even
if you get 90
love i get a tremendous amount of love
online you know you get still a
tremendous amount of hate
and even if you don't get hate uh just
getting love from strangers all the time
isn't great probably for the ego either
so there's just like so many things and
constantly
creating and putting stuff out there and
then that that mirror
that that stares back at you there's
just so many things about it that i was
just like
i don't know maybe i could try to live
like we did 20 years ago and
and see what happens um i know that a
lot of people can't do it at the level
that i'm about to do it's funny i've
been tweeting about it this morning
and a lot of people are saying that
they're going to join me for off the
grid and i am going to lock my phone in
a safe
my phone will be in a safe uh my ipad my
computer will all be in a safe
uh along with my gun they will all
and uh i know that the average person
probably can't take the whole month
without all of those things
um i may take a couple uh calls like
with family members on speakerphone from
david's phone but i'm not going to be
touching any of the things i mean
i'm really doing this at the most like
extreme level possible
and the only thing that we're going to
do uh
over the course of the month really is
as i said we're going to work on on diet
and exercise and relaxing and some
meditation and reading and all of that
kind of stuff
but we will also see people in real life
so you may remember
uh back in the old days uh when you had
to walk uphill both ways without shoes
in the cold to go see a friend
so we're gonna see friends we're to
invite friends and family to come over
to our house and talk about anything
other than politics
anything other than current events i
just want a reset
you know we're all caught in this rat
race people talk about
you know the 24-hour news cycle that's
what we used to talk about the 24-hour
news cycle right because we went from
having three networks abc nbc cbs
that you'd get your nightly news at 6 30
p.m basically and then you could read a
newspaper and that was the new cycle
then we had a 24-hour due cycle which
was cnn and fox news and msnbc
and then in the last 20 years or so
because of the internet and twitter
especially
we are constantly slammed with other
people's thoughts
all day long and then there's podcasts
and youtube and twitter and all those
things
and it's one of the reasons why you guys
say to me all the time dave why don't
you put out
seven shows a week every day should be a
new show you should be doing more and
more and more
and it's like i'm very respectful i
think of your time i mean we're
incredibly busy as is um but you know i
always feel like we don't all need to
always ingest
endless amounts of stuff even even
worthwhile stuff
i assume you have a life i have assumed
i assume maybe you have someone you love
or like
and you want to get outside and take a
walk and maybe you want to do some other
things
and learn how to cook or garden or maybe
you want to read or maybe you want to
even play video games or whatever it
else might be i guess video games you're
still connected to the
to the matrix but i just think that we
all are
caught in this thing that we that we
didn't have for thousands of years
and now we're all in it all the time and
if you watch the movie the matrix which
i watched again i've seen it a million
times but i watched it again at the
beginning of lockdown
you know basically we are living in the
matrix at some level
we are becoming the batteries our
organic
bodies are becoming the batteries for
the digital world
if you spend more than 12 hours a day
you spend 12 hours in one second a day
online
well then that's more of your life
that's more than half of your life and i
think a lot of us do spend
that much time on it and and if not even
if you spend five hours i mean you get
your
your uh iphone tells you you know you
you were online for six hours a day or
you used your phone for seven hours last
week a day or whatever it might be
we are putting so much energy into this
thing that we don't really understand
it's like a next
level of our collective brain kind of
thing
and i'm not saying all of that is bad my
life is is
immeasurably more incredible and
and and uh humbling and inspiring and
the whole thing because of this right
i'm doing this on youtube i've started a
couple companies i've got great people
that work for me i've met
a zillion friends and i've become
friends with people that i've admired
for years and
all sorts of wonderful stuff so it's not
to say it's all bad but the internet
like fire
is a tool right fire is great it can
keep you warm it can cook your food
it can also burn you and it can burn
down your house and i think the internet
is sort of very similar it's like it can
connect us
we can be part of this amazing worldwide
community we can share hobbies and
all of these things and pictures with
people with people that we
lost ago and all of that and that's all
wonderful and then it
other side that this attention zapping
sucking
light destroying side
um so that's why i decided to do
this four years ago that's why i'm doing
it this year so the first two years that
i did it i had ben shapiro bring me back
on the grid so i know nothing i avoid
absolutely everything and i've been able
to do it
actually for the first three years i've
been able to manage to do it
ben shapiro brought me back the first
two years glenn beck brought me back
last year uh we're gonna have a surprise
guest bringing me back on september 1st
september 1st happens to be a monday
uh which is nice so i will come back on
monday september 1st and it's a
different guest this time
um and uh before i bring on a couple of
our guests so i'm i'm bringing on three
people today i'm bringing on tristan
harris we're gonna talk about digital
detox
i'm gonna do like three 15-minute
interviews just to chat with
uh these guys and gal about uh their
area of expertise and how i can
incorporate more of that into my life
during this time off so i'm going to
talk to tristan harris
who for years has been talking about the
dangers of tech addiction i've had him
on the show before
we're going to talk first then i'm going
to talk to tom merrick he's uh he's a
fitness guy he's huge on
instagram he's not on twitter he's he's
a wise man
he's not on twitter and we're going to
talk about just some of the exercise
stuff
that i can do that hopefully you guys
are going to get as much worthy
and worthwhile information uh as i do
when i talk to
tom and when i talk to tristan and then
i'm gonna talk to michaela peterson who
most of you know of course she's jordan
peterson's daughter and she's sort of
the famed leader of the lion diet
movement which is that you
just eat red meat and as you guys know i
was on tour with jordan
and i saw the man just eat red meat he'd
have a rib eye for breakfast
two rib eyes usually for lunch and like
a tomahawk for dinner
uh and it helps him with all sorts of
health problems and i'll maybe she can
convince me to do it for at least a
couple days during that but we're going
to talk about diet with her so i'm going
to talk about digital detox
i'm going to talk about fitness and i'm
going to talk about diet with all these
people
uh i'm also going to take your questions
um which we don't do you know we don't
do super chat anymore the youtube
comments section is
is evil it's it's pure hell it's uh it's
a horrible horrible place
uh but if you want to submit some
questions to me uh
you can go to reubenreport.com or you
can download the reuben report
app on ios store or on google play
and you can submit some questions to me
right now oh and we are doing one other
uh different thing this year when i'm
off the grid although i will not
have any anything uh david will
have some device that occasionally he
will update people on what i'm doing so
if you want to
see some of the things that i'm doing
whether it's exercising or whether it's
cooking or whether it's gardening
or i don't know doing woodwork i'm going
to try to do
all sorts of interesting stuff
throughout the month
we will be giving occasional updates
there i won't be touching anything or
even talking to the camera nothing like
that
but he will be posting some interesting
stuff so you can sign up at
reubenreport.com for that
um i want to tell you a couple other
things before we jump in
uh with the guests um so first off
this also this is this is fairly big
news that i haven't said before
this will be our last show
in this studio that's right we are we
are moving on this has been
uh it's been truly incredible being here
we moved in here
in november of 2016 this was really
uh the the move that catapulted
everything else that got us to
independence
and freedom uh and we've we've loved
this house and my crew has worked out of
here for a long time
and it's been it's been great i mean
everybody that walks into this room
is like holy cow dave you you have done
it you've done it right
uh we've decided to move on for a couple
different reasons i want to shoot the
show a little bit differently going
forward
um you know and also because of
coronavirus obviously people are doing a
lot more on skype
and through the through the wires right
um so we're going to focus on that a
little bit more and then i'm going to
shoot in-person interviews in a totally
new way that i don't think anyone really
is doing right now
and it's going to be really cool look i
was one of the first people to do the
home studio thing
and and do the long-form interview thing
and it's time to reinvent again i always
say to my guys it's like we're back to
the beginning again
so we are back to the beginning again so
we're building some interesting stuff in
a new site
going forward and i'm super psyched to
share that with you and i think we're
going to do
interviews really truly in a way that
nobody else is doing them right now
and i'm really excited about that so
that is one thing that we will be
debuting in the fall in september
uh and two other big pieces of news
before we get to our guest
um i have signed my next book deal i'm
super psyched about that i
i just really enjoyed writing the book i
really did enjoy it and then
you know obviously the things that i
wrote about and don't burn this book
have been super
relevant for the last couple months
right like i mean well basically
everything i wrote it's as if i wrote it
in the last couple months
because i was talking about the
hysterical nature of the left
and destroying history and identity
politics and
you know i called it don't burn this
book but as i said i should have called
it don't burn the story that this book
is sold in
uh because we're watching we're watching
cities burn um
we're watching sort of the collapse
of liberalism which you can see as the
progressives just
destroy whatever is left of liberalism
and that takes out the democratic party
and that it's like what do i think many
of you feel this if you're sort of an
old-school liberal what do you do do you
try to fix that
that mess that scorched earth that
they've left or do you try to make
alliances
uh to conservatives and libertarians
obviously you know my choice on that and
that
i think a lot of my lefty friends are
going the other way i think they think
they can keep throwing people under the
bus or somehow reconstitute something
saying there i just don't think it'll
work
maybe they're right and if they are
that's fantastic um but all of the
things that i wrote about in the book
seem to be the exact things that we're
all talking about
all the time now so i loved writing the
book so i i just signed the deal on the
new book
and i don't think i'm going to do much
writing on it for august but i'm at
least going to start sketching the
outline and sort of see what i want to
do with it
i do have a name in mind but i'm not
going to say it yet they didn't want me
to say it and it's not totally
it's not totally totally uh there that
it's gonna be the one but
but i dig it it's cool and i think i
think i'm gonna really focus on new
ideas like i think i've
put the why i left the left thing to bed
i've put the regressive left thing to
bed
everyone sees that i guess i was kind of
right in the last couple years about
this stuff right even even people that
have spent tons of time hating me online
are kind of now just saying the same
stuff that i've been saying for years
that that's nice to hear that's nice to
hear um
but uh i'm gonna focus really on new
ideas like really exploring some new
stuff that i've been thinking about in a
new way so that is that
and then the other piece of uh september
and i'm just gonna give this a minor
tease for now
um you know even though as i said before
a lot of you asked me to do a seven day
a week thing and just keep putting out
more and more and more and i haven't
wanted to do it
one of the things that i've been
thinking about is that i do
want to do some version
of like a slightly more relaxed news
type of show and give you guys some
information without
without making you outraged without
without slamming you with
with endless nonsense and keeping you
clicking around stories and all of that
craziness so starting in september uh
it'll start on september 2nd tuesday
september 2nd
i'm going to be doing a three day a week
i think it will be live we're not 100
sure yet but i think it will be live
live show right here on this channel uh
which will be a
like a half hour news update uh we're
still working on format and tinkering
some stuff and all that
um but i think it will be a different
way of getting the news that won't make
you
totally angry and i'm not going to do it
to outrage you and i'm not going to do
it to keep you in a click hole
um but i'm really psyched and and we're
partnering up
uh with uh with somebody on that which
i'll explain all of that in september so
anyway we
we got a lot to do my guys although i
will be taking
august off the grid my guys obviously
have a ton to do oh and by the way we
have
new content throughout august as well
although i hope some of you will take
some degree
of time off some of this and as i said
before i know a lot of you guys are
trying it in your own way
um we have new shows coming out i just
taped an interview yesterday with dr
deborah so she's got a new book
called the end of gender coming out and
she's been on the show before and she's
fantastic and she's really fighting
against the sort of intersectional
movement that is that
is really throwing gay people in many
ways under the bus in the name
of trans rights so we we talk all about
that she's just great i just interviewed
sean hannity yesterday and if you like
hannity or even if you don't like
hannity
it's a spectacular interview you will
see this guy
in a completely new light like an hour
where he gets to talk with no
commercials
and no cable news craziness like it's
really really interesting
rob smith's got a new book out so i just
sat down with him and we've got a couple
other shows i think we've got like six
or eight shows
coming out in august which is more than
we normally do
uh but okay so i'm going to answer all
your questions as i said you can submit
them now
at reubenreport.com but without further
ado i'm going to bring on
our first guest who's going to talk to
me about digital detox
uh it is tristan harris who is the
co-founder no he yeah co-founder he's
the co-founder
of the center for humane technology and
he's been one of the guys
that has been uh on the leading edge of
saying hey something ain't right with
big tech
and uh these devices are making us crazy
tristan how are you
i'm good how are you dave good to see
you i am good i suspect i will be better
in about a week from now
can you can you tell me why my brain
might feel a little bit better
in a week from now when i put down all
of these devices you've been doing
you've been talking about this like
pretty much before
anybody yeah well um
uh and i suspect you mean are you
starting your vacation in a week from
now is that why you say week now as
opposed to it'll take seven days
to kick in well i'm starting it tonight
but i suspect yeah it'll take
i know from the other times that i've
done it like the first few days
it's kind of weird i want to jump back
on i keep going in my pocket to find my
phone
but then after like five or seven days
that's when sort of the
the relaxing part of it or the calming
part kicks in but you can walk me
through all of it actually
it's like the seven stages of grief the
seven stages of disconnection or
something like that
um you know i think you know you've
actually taken a longer
um break from social media multiple
years in a row than
than i have and all these things so i
think you you're uh
more than an expert than i am but for
those people don't know my background
why
you know we'd be talking about this um
you know i used to be a design
ethicistic google where it was basically
my job
to i made it my job for three years to
study how do we fix
the attention economy the fact that a
handful of these tech companies their
business model is to commodify and turn
you know a live human consciousness into
dead slabs of human attention that can
be monetized in the same way that
you know living trees get turned into
lumber um and so long just like lumber
is worth
uh you know more than a tree as it's
alive you know dead slabs of human
consciousness
in the form of engagement and zombie
scrolling are worth more than a human
being living their life uh
in an attention-aligned way so you know
and and also speaking to you know many
of the harms that i'm sure you know
we'll get into
maybe another time about what happens
when the business model is whatever is
good for your attention it's much better
to give you feeds that affirm
your view of the world and things that
constantly give you different views of
the world
um but you know i think when we first
met it's interesting looping back around
because we met before apple launched all
those screen time features time well
spent all that stuff came after and much
as a result of our work
which is just to say that you know when
the business model is keeping people's
attention
you're fighting an uphill battle when it
comes to personal responsibility
um there's only so much that we can do
especially when our lives are so
entangled
um with the way these things work i mean
saying don't use technology is almost
like saying don't use your right hand
because it's kind of become a prosthetic
or an extension of how we interact in
the world i mean
if you're a teenager you say oh you know
i actually don't want to use
instagram or snapchat all your friends
are gonna start gossiping about you on
it
and if you're not on there to sort of
deal with whatever fallout is coming
it's it's irresponsible and so there's
this kind of entanglement that we're all
feeling as well
but what i think is interesting is you
know very few people are going through
the experience that you're doing
of actually completely unplugging and i
think
i'd love to ask you like what what is
because i think i think people need to
see is how surprising it is
how how big the impact is i think that's
the thing people miss is
it's not just like oh i'm using it i can
right now because i'm plugged in and
i've been on zoom calls all day since
7am
i can easily imagine what it's going to
be like when i'm not on there but i
think i'd be curious to ask you
what is the surprising gap about like
can you right now empathize with what
you're going to be feeling seven days
from now
yeah well it's kind of funny because
since i've done it a couple times i sort
of know what to expect but i also know
that there will be surprises
along the way so last year i remember
specifically
we were away and i was laying on a beach
and suddenly
old songs that i have not thought about
in a long time
started playing in my head like my brain
had had enough time to just
nothing just stare at the ocean and not
go to the pocket and not do this and and
old songs were popping in my head and
then i
i remember very specifically i looked
around the beach and we're sitting at
this gorgeous beach right like beautiful
ocean in front of us
it's it's still it's silent gorgeous
water and i'm looking
and almost everyone is looking at their
device they're not looking at the ocean
they're not they're not looking at their
feet in the sand they're looking at that
so what what is cool for me is that for
as much as i intellectually know
sort of what's going to happen over the
next month and how good i'm going to
feel
i remember the morning last year when i
came back on i said to david that
morning
i was like i feel like a million bucks
right now like i felt calmer
i felt more i felt more connected to
reality all of those things i mean these
are the things you've been talking about
can you just mention a little bit about
because i think people don't really
sort of fully grasp how they've tried to
hook us on these things
like things like endless scrolling like
it wasn't always endless scrolling and
now it's just
endless scrolling and how that in and of
itself is one of the things that just
gets you yeah totally so um
you know also to give people context um
my background going to this was as a kid
i was a magician which is
all about recognizing that the human
mind is not this like
authoritative instrument that sees
reality and cause and effect perfectly
magic is all about saying where could
that mind be undermined hijack
manipulated without the other person's
awareness
and obviously magic is a field that
works so obviously it's possible that
that's true
um and to your point i i studied at a
lab at stanford called the stanford
persuasive technology lab
with the founders of instagram and uh
and many other people who went on to
become
the people who created this industry um
a professor named bj fogg and
and what basically what we learned in
that in that course is what are all of
these
um vulnerabilities in the human mind and
the same way that a magician is looking
for them so
uh social approval um one of these funny
examples about persuasion is there's
some kind of persuasion where even if
you know that it's a persuasive trick it
actually still works on you
so for example flattery feels good even
if i tell you it's completely made up
like dave i actually love the shirt that
you're wearing
it's like it's a great shirt thank you
thank you thank you appreciate it
and if i was bullshitting you uh you
would still feel uh good even because
it's just that's how our minds work we
actually seek social approval
so there i am if i'm instagram and like
people really like social approval
what if i actually gave you variable
doses variable squirts of social
approval on a random timeline
and every single time you check your
phone you get just a little bit more
that is such deep ingrained psychology
that that's how these things can be
designed so to your example of that
infinite scroll
it wasn't always that that we built
technology to just scroll forever
in fact um my co-founder at our
nonprofit the center for humane
technology
uh azer raskin actually invented the
infinite scroll and he gave talks all
around silicon valley
he estimates that it weighs something
like gosh i'm forgetting the number it's
like 700 000
hours a day or something some crazy
number um
and the point was that your mind so one
of the features of our mind is it relies
on these things called stopping cues
um in a conversation how do you know
when to leave because the person stops
talking that creates a gap that's a
stopping cue
and thank god because you didn't want to
be in that conversation you get to walk
away
um and we all we all know those people
who don't give us those stopping cues
they keep talking talking talking
talking they don't give us that stopping
queue so you have to kind of
you have to eject yourself and that's
kind of like what's happening with
technology um
in the race to the bottom of the
brainstem for what's who's going to go
lower
you know in your brains tend to get
attention removing that stopping cue
saying you know use the scroll and then
i would say hey do you want to load more
you know load 10 more stories and you
scroll and you get 10 more stories
almost portion sizing you know how much
we're giving
attention out but as soon as like let's
say facebook says you know what we're
going to take away
that that stopping key we're going to go
to infinite scroll then instagram
facebook youtube
all the other companies they have to do
the same thing too they have to match it
because it's like game theory if you
have 10 nukes i have to have 10 news if
you have
you know if you remove infinite scroll i
have to remove the stopping queues i
have to remove the stop
cues and so that's how this stuff works
but it's gotten
so powerful that you know and it's also
embedded into our lives that it's sort
of like saying someone has made my arm
not as useful to me as possible but as
useful to getting me to reach for things
for them
as they want it to do and when there's
that entanglement that's what's so
hard and i think it you know it speaks a
little bit to the antitrust hearings
that just happened in
washington dc a couple days ago which is
the premise that
like these things that are so intimately
woven into our lives have to be
uh more neutrally uh in our interest
made in for
the public interest and not for
commercial interest because you know if
i was a
neurosurgeon and i put a brain implant
into your brain and it was driven by the
business model of advertising and what i
wanted you to think about
we would say no we don't allow brain
implants that do that that's a bad
business model for brain implants
but when we create a brain implant yet
we've done it
yeah we've done it and it's funny you
know i talked to the neurolink guys
which is the elon musk
company too and you know like they're
kind of veering into that terrain
you know as well uh i think this is the
kind of thing we have to actually really
think about and what's so interesting is
that
you going on this break for a month is
kind of like saying i'm gonna forcibly
take out the neuro
implant which means i lose access to you
know the fast news processing and who
said what and
infinite anxiety fed to you on a silver
platter um
and you know we have that we have that
agency but it's this kind of
all-or-nothing choice as opposed to
wouldn't it be nice if we had humane
brain implants
that weren't commercialized that weren't
so adversarial to our interests
and actually you know helped us be more
responsible with how he's our attention
yeah i'm i'm guessing that you either
saw i'm guessing you either saw the
movie or read the book but ready player
one remember
at the end i forget what they call the
alt the digital universe in it
um do you remember off the top of your
head whatever whatever they call it
but but when he takes over when i ca i
only saw it once but when
when the kid takes over at the end and
he now controls the online world
one of the things he installs is that
you basically have to take two days off
a week i think that's what it is and
at least that's what it was in the movie
and it's like that's kind of a pretty
good thing and
you know there we go but i really like
the analogy you just use about the arm
that sounds like a philip k
dick uh short story does it like your
arm is possessed by somebody else
um but but quick before before we wrap
up for the people that are watching this
that they know what you're saying is
true
they're they're feeling the crunch of
big tech and the distraction and all of
that stuff
but they can't do what i'm about to do
they can't do the month
um i know you've got a couple tricks
maybe that
people can do so as a magician give me a
couple digital detox tricks that people
could try to
incorporate into their lives so that
they can do it without maybe
locking their phone in a safe but but
something that's a little less extreme
that might help them
yeah you wouldn't want to lock your arm
in a safe and then not be able to use it
so
um the yeah i mean the simple thing is
obviously to turn off all notifications
i mean it's so underestimated
um the impact of an interruption uh on
our on our psyche
um there's a woman named gloria mark at
uc irvine who studied something called
interruption science for the last decade
and
on a computer when you get interrupted
by someone it could be any
external interruption a person or a
notification it takes us on average
23 minutes to resume the thing that we
were doing and we actually cycle through
two
projects before we go back to this is
like if you're working but that kind of
thing it's a really big cost
but the simple thing is just turn off
all notifications i actually have
and i know this is speaking to um not
everybody can resource this but if you
have separate computers or separate
devices for
uh say things like slack or something
like that where you have you know the
fast rapid communication versus
when you get your work done um
personally just to share a personal
story
i actually just got a desktop computer
for the first time in like a decade i
mean i've never had like a sit-down
workstation desktop always just these
laptops obviously you know why would you
need it but there's something about
having like a
a place that just only when i sit down
at it and i do my work
and then i'm it creates this kind of
stopping key or boundary because then i
can walk away from it as opposed to the
laptop i'll just take with me
everywhere with a smartphone so first
thing obviously turn off all
notifications um
recognizing that most times we get
notifications it's because
these private tech companies are are
inventing reasons to keep you coming
back like hey there's a new episode of
the reuben report
on the youtube thing you should probably
swipe over and watch it yep um obviously
i mean you could you could leave that
one obviously but i get your
major point yes exactly um
you know uh we used to tell people to go
grayscale which was kind of an
experiment
more in the pattern interrupt so there's
something in neurolinguistic programming
in hypnosis called a pattern interrupt
when you look at your screen and you see
these colorful icons it's like at a low
level in your
like dopamine system it's kind of
activating these juicy rewards
the expectation there might be something
for me and if you turn your phone
grayscale which you can do by going into
on an iphone general settings general
accessibility
and then scroll all the way to the
bottom to the accessibility shortcut
and you can make it so that when you
triple click the right hand side of your
phone or double click the
thumb touch id thing it'll switch the
phone into grayscale mode and the power
of that is
when you look at your phone and it's in
grayscale it takes away just a little
bit of that kind of juicy sexy factor
and it makes it just a little bit less
interesting and more importantly it
it's a reminder it's a pattern about
because you look at your phone you
realize oh right i want to be using this
less
i think for all these things to work
though people actually have to have
a real commitment that they make they
have to ask themselves do i really want
to use this less do i really want to
have a different relationship to my
phone because if you don't start with
that intention
then these things are just empty tricks
that are not really going to do anything
it starts with obviously you have to
have
some sense of personal responsibility
intentionality and then if you can
honestly
take a day off a week just don't even
bring it with you at all because
we underestimate there's there's
evidence that even having a smartphone
on a table between two people talking
actually reduces the amount of presence
and connection that two people feel even
if you've never used it or even looked
at it
just the fact that it's there and i
think you know if you take a sunday
where you don't even have it in your
pocket or near you
just leave it at home a full digital
sabbath it sounds so simple but
it really has a big impact and i really
recommend people try it
yeah one of the things i mentioned this
in my book actually one of the things i
was doing at restaurants
remember in the old days when you could
go to restaurants uh i'd go out with
friends remember
with friends yeah and we i would i did
this a couple times where we would all
put our phones
in a stack on the center of the table
and it was whoever grabbed their phone
first had to pay for dinner and it
worked a couple times because it kept
people off
because otherwise what happens always at
dinner it's the same thing
i find you can get eight people around a
table and if nobody looks at their phone
if nobody's doing it then no everyone
will kind of respect it
the second one person does it everyone
sees that moment that's sort of
the stop gap that you're talking about
and then everybody is like okay yeah and
next thing you know five minutes later
you don't even realize you're sitting
with seven other people totally exactly
and it's actually just the suggestion we
used to do this an experiment um my
co-founder
and i used to do where i would just put
this on the table and i would just reach
for it just to touch it not even to pick
it up just reach for it to touch it and
you would actually notice in your own
psyche you would feel the need to touch
your own phone just by even
action we're so suggestible this is what
i learned from hypnosis i mean
suggestion is such a subtle and
invisible thing if you just
point attention at something and just
activate like
because your brain is doing prediction
right you're always sort of imagining
what would happen if
and when someone reaches open grabs
their phone your brain sort of runs a
quick mental process of like what will
that feel like for me
and that's why it's so viral i mean it's
like before the coronavirus there is
sort of phone reaching virus and that's
uh you know it's a very powerful virus
that you gotta you gotta
i mean we're basically pavlov's dog it's
like you reach and next thing you know
you're drooling for that phone
uh well listen tristan i i appreciate
you doing this and i'll get you back on
in the fall right when i come back and
we can
kind of do a do a download so to speak
about what we've talked about here but
if you happen to make it to la in the
next month it might be interesting to
see you in person so
you you know where you can reach out to
my guys because that that might be
something
i might be down in l.a in august or
september so let's uh let's make it
happen more on the other
all right great well you guys can follow
tristan on
twitter if you want to be on the twitter
it's just at tristan harris right
yep and we also if anybody's interested
in learning more about the effects of
technology in society
we have a podcast called your undivided
attention so
great awesome well thanks so much and
i'll see you in september
thanks dave all right
that is the first of the three mini
interviews that i'm doing today that'll
sort of frame exactly what i'm going to
be doing for the next month and i hope
they're giving
or they will all give you a little
something to maybe incorporate in your
life in august you know
before the the crazy 24-hour news cycle
you know the other thing about august
was august used to be the time
and before coronavirus and lockdowns and
everything else where most of us would
take a family vacation when i was
growing up
my family would always do that last week
in august before we go back to school
we'd go to i
grew up in new york we would go to lake
george or we would go to the jersey
shore
or we'd go to vermont or something like
that um i think that
if there's ever a time to do some level
of disconnect for anybody i do think it
is august i know it feels even weirder
now i mean
the weird thing because of the lockdowns
and coronavirus is we all
we were all on this stuff endlessly
endlessly before all of it and then what
happened then we all got stuck at home
and then we were all we're now all on it
even more i mean
just think about your day if you're not
going into the office anymore if you're
not commuting anymore whatever it might
be
the amount of time that we've all given
to all of these things and again that is
not to say that these things are all
inherently evil
and i actually wanted to mention
something to tristan about you know he's
now working with some of the people that
you know the guy that did infinite
scroll it's like
i don't think that guy is inherently
evil i would love to chat with him
actually
um but like these tools have been given
to us and i think that's sort of why the
internet feels so crazy we got all of
these tools
and we're like kids with very advanced
tools we're still in our
technological adolescence with things
that we have no
idea what they are so that's why i'm
doing it i am going to talk to tom
merrick in a couple minutes
tom is uh is a fitness guy he's huge on
on instagram i said to my guys let's
find
somebody that is big in the fitness
world that can just
lay it out for me what do i need to do
i've got a bum shoulder i got a banged
up
corn acl in my knee but what are some of
the things that i can do
during this break that i can do at home
by the way because i can't even go to
the gym i actually just canceled my gym
membership first off
i don't even think you can go to the gym
here in l.a right now
but i cancel my gym membership anyway
because i want because there's so many
freaking televisions
at the gym that in the years past when
i've tried to go and stay off the grid i
have to wear a
low hat and i basically have to look
down the entire time because there's
news everywhere i mean that's another
thing
the way we've been slammed with at the
gym
or you go to a burger joint or you go to
a bowling alley or wherever you go
basically
and cnn and fox news and msnbc are on on
tvs everywhere that that's not healthy
i think you're allowed to go to a
bowling alley and think about bowling i
think you're allowed to go to the gym
and not think about the news
but at my gym here you know when when i
was doing cardio they'd have like 40
machines lined up like this and they'd
literally have 15 televisions
cnn cnn msnbc fox cnn cnn cn
bc nbc and it's like it's just like this
endless
thing that we're all just kind of caught
in all right so i'm going to talk to
uh i'm going to talk to tom in just a
couple minutes reminder i will be taking
some of your questions if you submit
them right now
at reubenreport.com and uh to catch you
guys up if you're just jumping in right
now
uh my new book will be coming out it'll
be coming out next year
i think i think next year the publishing
process does take a while but i have
signed my new book deal so i'm really
psyched about that and i'm thrilled to
be working
uh with the people at penguin random
house again and uh and i think you're
gonna really dig the direction of it
i'll probably
maybe i'll make the announcement of the
title and sort of the direction of the
book when i get back in september
uh also i will be doing a three day a
week i think live we're not 100 sure yet
but i think live show in the mornings
on tuesdays wednesdays and thursdays
starting on september 2nd and i'll
i'll announce the partnership on that uh
come september 2nd and i'm i'm super
psyched and i think it's going to
be a really nice expansion of everything
i'm doing without
bludgeoning you guys with with the daily
headlines
um we're not going to blow up your phone
we're not going to blow up your phone
with that stuff all right you know why
don't we do a couple questions
uh right now uh michael if you oh there
we go
i've got an ipad here this is the last
time i'll be looking at a bright
ipad here uh patty so these are all from
reubenreport.com which is our locals.com
community
and just a reminder guys if you are a
creator of any kind or if you own a
non-profit or a business or anything
else
and you want to have the tools to build
a digital home
for you and monetize it and create a
great community without big tech just
check out what we're doing with locals
um patty says have you asked to
interview trump yes
we have and actually we've made a little
headway
and i have a short list basically of
four things that i told my guys that i
can be pulled back on the grid for
and one of them is if trump's people
respond and say
you got to get to dc we're willing to do
it today yes i will get back on the grid
for that
um but i'm hoping that it doesn't
actually happen in august i hope we can
do it in the fall but we have reached
out
we've gotten good response from them you
know he just did the thing with dave
from
bar stool sports which by the way i
thought was a fantastic interviewer
i like to think i know a little
something about interviewing i thought i
thought dave did a
great job dave portnoy a lot a lot of
people gave him crap and then the mob
tried to take out barstool and it's like
he did a really nice job and i thought
trump got to open up in a way that he
usually doesn't
but yes i i'm pretty sure we will get
trump before the election and we are
going to certainly
we are certainly going to try um let's
see
uh oh this is a great question from
megan seeing how crazy our country is
getting do you have any concerns that
you might miss something crucial to your
health or
safety during the month of no news
whether it's riots near your home that
you might not be aware of
uh or something like that and do you
have a safety feature in place if news
information is essential so look
we did think about this and as i said
i've got these four things that i can be
brought back
on the grid for could there be a
horrific terrorist attack
could there be a um you know we had
three earthquakes two days ago here in
l.a i woke up three three times
at night one was a 4.2 at 4 30 in the
morning that woke everybody up
then there were two smaller ones like
could some stuff
happen that then could really affect my
life where i need a phone and i need to
be able to communicate with people
of course of course so like those things
exist and then on top of it you know
it's not fun to think about it but you
know we've had riots and protests and
everything else
um you know la obviously hasn't been as
bad as
portland for sure where there are
terrorists basically i mean antifa is a
terrorist organization in my opinion
you've got terrorists roaming the
streets
um you know we're not as bad as portland
we're not as bad as seattle could there
be a certain set of things i've laid it
out
that i could be dragged back in for yes
and and of course you know david will
have
his phone he's going to try to do a
little bit of a detox as well but like
we're not going to be uh
you know world war three if world war
three happens
we'll have some way of getting some
information about that but i did have to
think about that which is kind of
depressing
it's kind of depressing at one level and
on the other level it's like oh well
that's exactly why i'm taking the time
off because we're not supposed to live
in this thing all the time but but could
some horrific things happen
um yes it's possible i i'm trying to
think i was thinking about this
yesterday could something that is
so great happen that i would i would be
shook
i would be needed to be shook back
online
i don't know what that would be that i
would almost prefer would actually be
kind of cool let's say on
august 15 let's say august 15th
something like spectacularly amazing
happens i don't know what that is like
would i need to know it before i came
back on i don't know and that's a weird
thing about the news it's like when
something good happens you almost don't
need to know it
something seemingly horrific happens and
you kind of feel like you have to know
it that's just sort of interesting piece
of the psychology of all this
but all right let's jump on with tom
merrick he is a fitness
instructor a lifestyle expert and a guy
that's going to
help a 44 year old with a with a bum
shoulder and a torn acl in his knee he's
going to give me a little advice
for this month off the grid tom how you
doing i'm good thank you
how are you doing i'm all right so
listen
we've never spoke before but when i said
to my guys
look i want somebody in the fitness
world that
can spend 15 minutes with me setting me
up for this month you know really where
i want to i want to come back i'm going
to try to eat right sleep right
all the things that we all kind of
forget about sometimes and and work out
at home and hopefully come back a little
a little leaner trimmer
maybe a little more buff they said all
right almost everybody said you got to
talk to tom
so help me out here man i've got a month
what should i be focusing on
oh man i feel like the first thing is
you you're going to need more than a
month
well i got to let's start me with a
month how about yeah and then
get me on the right foot of course i'll
continue after and i do a pretty decent
job right now but like
if someone had a month to really just
like start the reset what would you say
um you know what i think
that the key would be to kind of avoid
all the
i guess you would say insta virus sort
of posts out there it's been quite an
interesting one to
observe like something i do bodyweight
training that's like my my thing i guess
flexibility sort of stuff
um and then there's sort of been this
like influx of stuff since covered
everyone's trying to
capitalize on the your training at home
now make the most of it sort of stuff
but
a lot of it is um just just not
not great and i'm not saying this to
discredit people it's just that
kind of you presume that if you're
training at home things can't be hard
you know you haven't got any weight you
haven't got any equipment like how how's
that going to be hard like it's just
easy you got to do
100 reps of mountain climbers and and
all this like crazy
um sort of hit sort of stuff but
actually body weight training can be
pretty damn hard and i think that's
probably the key component that i would
suggest to you to do
um during this time is like make sure
your training remains
pretty intense yeah all right so talk to
me about like
talk to me about like kind of duration
and like the type of stuff i've been
doing so first off i do have a bunch of
free
weights i got a whole bunch of different
freeways i've even got battle ropes
i don't use them too often right now but
i've got some battle ropes
um i've got i know you do more on on the
muscle side but i've got an elliptical
machine
um so like kind of lay out like sh is
should i be doing stuff seven days a
week do you want to give your body a
rest like what's
what's a good way for someone listening
to this that just doesn't do anything
but they just want to start
lifting start moving like what should we
be doing
certainly every day isn't an essential
um
i think for most people three to four
times a week is more than enough
uh you know if if you're doing if you're
doing too much and also you've done
nothing beforehand that is a great
recipe to get more injuries i know you
said you're injured already
so we don't we don't add to that um
three or four days per week
and doing something like full body three
days a week or maybe an upper lower
um four times a week that's the sort of
thing that's that's really simple to
implement
and gives you plenty of rest in between
like this so give me full body
what what's full body what am i doing i
wake up i'm gonna
i'm gonna have a little breakfast have a
little coffee i'm gonna get there what
am i doing
um so i would personally stick to
something that is kind of
to do with german body composition
training so i would take an upboarding
exercise and i would pair it with a
light body exercise
and i'd do so three supersets so for
example super straightforward we could
do
a pull up with a squat um
something like in the in the six to
eight rep range would be nice and simple
uh with all of these you're kind of
thinking reasonable controlling
movements
quick up slow down that kind of applies
to everything um
no no rest in between nice quick
superstar and then like three minutes
between that
we're gonna have still have lots of rest
we don't want to be going down the route
of like hit training because it doesn't
allow us to hit that intensity
that we need to stimulate a lot of the
muscle growth um and those different
pathways so you want to keep things hard
that'd be your first one the second one
we do something like
a handstand push-up an overhead press
that sort of thing and we probably pair
that with a hamstring exercise that
could be
a straight leg deadlift it could be a
good morning it could be
a hamstring curl using sliders on the
floor
anything like that kind of think of it
as taking an upper body compound
movement a lower body compound movement
think opposite sides of the body so push
with pull the legs and hamstrings and
and pull the upper body would push the
lower body and just combine the two
together nice and simple
how much time should this be taken a day
i think
if you're just doing strength training
anything longer than like 45 to 60
minutes is a little bit overkill
um you know it you can you can get a
really effective workout especially you
know if you're doing like three times a
week if you're hitting full body three
times a week
45 minutes is is more than enough yeah
definitely
yeah where does cardio fit into that
um does it fit into it at all well
considering you're talking about this
like technological detox sort of side of
things
i think probably the best cardio is to
get outside
obviously there's a whole bunch of
benefits to just being outside in nature
getting some sunlight
um not being inside of artificial light
but yeah certainly
for me cardio wise i think sprints are
probably one of the best things that
people can implement
no equipment it gets you outside it gets
you in the sun
it gets you breathing some fresh air and
and there's and then it's also
pretty much endless possibilities you
know you can do something
as brutal as doing um eight second
sprint
12 second rest repeating 60 times 60
times
that sounds about right it's about 20
minutes um or you can do something a
little bit
a little bit less intense like a
30-second all-out sprint rest two
minutes between
repeat that sort of 8-10 times those are
just like
20 minutes three balls of the wall for
those 20 minutes um
but they're just a great way to get
outside that or just you know go for
like a three or four hour walk you don't
want to do something that is
in between that black hole areas kind of
avoid that 60 minutes of something
that's not quite hard enough to
stimulate that higher end and
not quite easy and slow enough to
stimulate that lower end
yeah so i'm going to talk to michaela
peterson in a couple of minutes about
sort of diet in a broad sense of what i
want to kind of be eating throughout the
month
but if i start doing this so let's say
strength training four days a week then
i'm mixing up with cardio and walks and
i'll get out there with my dog for a
couple miles a day
and all that kind of stuff um on the on
the strength training side though
um i feel like people are always
confused about what they're supposed to
eat before and what they're supposed to
eat right after
and then when i'm at the gym i see guys
that are downing
you know black coffee while they're
working out and some people say don't
eat before
and then some people want all these
carbs after or like some
there's like so much conflicting stuff
on that what's your policy
um sure i think you know caffeine
obviously performance enhancing
substance
caffeine is great um black coffee
beforehand i'm just a big coffee fan in
general so
i'd always be about the coffee um black
coffee there you go uh i always get
jealous when i'm in like uk time i'm
speaking to somebody
over in the u.s i'm like oh damn they're
just drinking coffee and it's like too
late for me to have anything
um but yeah certainly coffee beforehand
you can eat if you want to
you don't have to um obviously not
eating can impact performance to some
extent but
for the most part it's not it's going to
be a much of a muchness um
i i think definitely
most of the diet advice out there is
geared towards people who want to lose
weight so you need to take that into
account somebody searched yourself
you probably don't need to lose too much
weight if anything you're looking more
towards the
growing some form of muscle um and in
which
carbs are pretty useful i'm actually
personally a massive fan of stanford's
vertical diet
for anyone out there that is a super
super simple way of applying
like diet and nutrition it kind of
aligns down of what michaela will
probably talk to you about that
carnivore-esque kind of style diet
i'm a big fan of the meat-based diet i
think meat has a lot of benefits
especially some of those organ meats um
but
what i like is is stan effering he just
he brings in like the importance of
carbohydrates for
athletic performance at the end of the
day you're going to be training like an
athlete you're going to do some strength
training
you learn some cardio doing all this
activity you want to also support your
body and performing that if you go
zero carbs yes it's doable but it's also
gonna be much more stressful and
you know if you're not adapt to that it
probably is probably gonna affect your
performance so
carbs post training never a bad thing
right so so you pretty much hit the nail
on the head like i don't really want to
i'm not trying to lose a lot of weight
obviously i'm basically in good shape
but everyone's got or at least i've got
you know that that three pound thing
on the belly i'm i'm 44. it used to be
easier to get rid of
i could you know if i if i had like a
crazy month of eating in the summer or
something like i could pretty much get
rid of it almost immediately
um it does take a little more time right
now
uh what do you think about that thing
because that's that's the part of the
body i think everybody's always looking
at
um i i would honestly like if we're
going generic in price here obviously
it'd be something a little bit different
if we get individual but generic like
sprints and low carb for maybe some
cycling like
having low carb one day higher carb on
your training day something like that
would actually be very
quick and simple as a way of playing but
i know you have an acl injury which i
just remembered
recommending expenses maybe isn't well
that's what that's why i do i don't i
don't really run outside like i don't go
running on the street but i do
elliptical because you know you're just
going like this
you know torn acl it's okay you can
think super hard like as hard as you can
with that one for a little bit and then
easier the nice thing about sprinting i
guess elliptical as well as you'll get
the whole body involved yeah
so since i'm doing a digital detox
situation here
uh this morning when i was tweeting
about what i'm doing today i was trying
to tag you on twitter
you're not even on twitter you're an
instagram guy why did you make that
decision
my friends just say like i'm a boomer
already because i don't understand
twitter i'm like
i i used to do it when i was younger but
i just i didn't really get it it was
like lots of people shouting in the room
i kind of understand i think it's a cool
medium but um i try to make my life as
as uncomplex as possible and and twist
is just another thing but i would have
to update and keep track of them
um for me i just prefer keeping it
simple like i don't actually really
watch the news
too much anyway um i kind of my news i
get from my parents they're like oh did
you hear about this i'm like i have no
idea that was happening
um so wise man
why isn't this naive i don't know yeah
all right well listen where can uh where
can people find you on instagram and
anywhere else
so they can check out what you've been
doing sure they can uh youtube you're
mostly on youtube right
yeah i do a lot of flexibility stuff
flexibility is probably my main thing
but i do
here on youtube um i think that's a
great one great one about just unlocking
your body's ability to
i think you know not being able to touch
the toes not being able to do it sit in
a squat all of these sort of things can
can feel quite restrictive and your
body's fully capable so
certainly i'm big on flex busy but yeah
you can search my name on youtube
or on instagram and it'll come up and if
you like stretching or if you want to
get some stretching or handstands or
bodyweight stuff but yeah that's what i
do
all right well listen i appreciate you
doing this
yeah well listen i i appreciate you
doing this and although i won't have a
phone
i may have david snap some pictures of
what i'm doing and send them to you and
you you can give me some advice
throughout the month
all right that's it all right great
thanks so much appreciate it thank you
for having me
all right that was tom eric so he's a
humble guy he didn't even want to give
you the name of his
youtube channel directly so you can just
search tom merrick in youtube and he's
he's doing all sorts of interesting
stuff and i'm not kidding all my guys
were like
tom's the guy you want to talk to on on
fitness for the type of stuff that you
want to do so there you go
all right so i'm going to talk to
michaela peterson in a couple minutes
we're going to talk about the lion diet
i was on her podcast a couple weeks ago
actually and we we talked all about
uh about diet obviously but then also
about what it was like to be on on tour
with her dad and a little bit of updates
on him so maybe she can invite us
enlighten us a bit on that um all right
let me jump into
some of the questions uh be music asks
what are you gonna mismo
um well i think what i'll miss most
honestly is
is mostly what's going on in the reuben
report community i mean we've really
created like a fantastic community
of people with no trolls and no bots i
mean that
that was the whole idea that i wanted to
create with locals that i i wanted to
build digital homes for creators i
i believe you can say whatever you want
uh outside of my home but i don't invite
everybody into my home to say whatever
they want and just to wreck the place
and so we've started to create these
little digital i would say walled gated
communities walls are okay people
and we've created digital communities
where you set the rules as the creator
and you can
and welcome in whoever you want and it
does cost a couple bucks a month
everybody every creator on local sets
their own price
so that you're gonna get a certain type
of person and it is better than
the interactions you get in most of the
other places where it's free although
they did steal your soul
uh because people have burner accounts
and you know a million accounts where
they can just attack you anonymously and
all that so i will miss a lot of the
good
interactions um especially you know in
the reuben port community one of the
things we've done is i got people
sending me all sorts of recipes all the
time the books they're reading
family trips that they're taking all art
that they're making like so many
interesting cool things
so i will miss some of that stuff um for
the month but and as i said we will
post some stuff of me behind the scenes
but you know the positive interactions
because again
as i said this is not all negative it's
not that i'm sitting here saying the
internet is evil and
and social media is all horrible and
blah blah it's it's
incredible in so many ways um but
sometimes you also have to take a
separation from
from the good stuff um let's see
usually you go on a trip in august when
you check out and go off the grid any
destinations
we're not going anywhere this year we've
done different beach situations
for the last couple years we are just
we're going to hunker down
at home as i mentioned before we're in a
this is my last show in this studio so
we are going to be rebuilding some stuff
and we're going to be doing some work
and i like doing
a lot of the physical stuff too so we we
will be doing that kind of stuff
we're just going to be home and we'll
you know david will put some calls out
to people if they want to come over for
dinner
and and hang out and relax and and
that'll be it i guess we'll
we'll watch some movies so i will watch
movies i'm not going to watch
television but like if something's on
netflix we'll
watch something if any of you guys have
some netflix recommendations people love
giving netflix oh my god you've got to
watch that thing you have you ever seen
that thing it's the most amazing thing
i've ever seen
they love netflix recommendations we're
sort of out of stuff to watch right now
i haven't really found anything we just
watched the
handmaid's tale which i totally like um
although it was reverse when tanmay's
tail was out everyone kept saying this
is trump's america but it's much more
what the left is ushering in
in authoritarian evilness than what
trump is ushering in but that's a side
note
we're watching the last castle or the
last kingdom or the something something
i don't know i fall asleep in the middle
of it
it's basically uh game of thrones
without dragons it's like what are you
doing over there where are the dragons
um the crazy years asks me what is your
favorite tasty tropical drink while on
vacation
and how many can you down before
becoming embarrassing i've got a great
new drink and i don't know that i think
i made it up
and i want people to be having it it is
it well i don't know that i
i don't know that i fully made it up
because it's a sort of uh
margarita situation but i would like
people to call it the dave
uh what i do now on the weekends if
we're just you know
most of you know i'm a red wine guy so i
like a glass of red wine at night
but during the day if we're hanging out
if we're barbecuing whatever it is
everybody loves a margarita so what i've
been doing it's sort of a make
it's almost a cross between a margarita
and a mojito
so what i do is i take take a glass fill
it up to the top with ice
i do like just a little bit almost like
a
quarter of a shot glass of tequila
uh not tequila of lime juice quarter
quarter shot glass lime juice put that
in first
then i do about a shot and a half of
tequila
i've been doing patron lately but
whatever your tequila of choices
shot and a half of that then i take real
watermelon juice real watermelon juice
like you can just get a little one
because a little one you only need
like a splash of it i'll do maybe like
two splashes
splash or two of real watermelon juice
and then i fill up the rest either with
just straight up club soda
or with watermelon club soda or you
could add any other flavor club soda
that you want that you can mix
that you feel like will mix well with
watermelon and lime stir it up and it's
sort of it's not purely it's tequila
based with lime so it's
it sort of feels like a margarita but
you've also got club soda in there so it
kind of feels like
a mojito and you can also you can muddle
some i haven't done this yet no no i did
do it once
i did do it once but then i put it in a
blender and it didn't work out that well
because club soda in a blender ain't
gonna work
but you could muddle some lime in there
uh sorry muddle some uh
some mint in there as well um so that's
it so one more time
take a glass fill it up with ice you're
gonna put about a quarter of a shot
glass of lime juice in there you're
gonna put about two splashes
of fresh grape uh fresh watermelon juice
i've done this with grape juice
two which was weird uh and then you're
gonna put either just straight up club
soda
or you're gonna put watermelon flavored
club soda or whatever else whatever
other flavor you think will work in
there and just stir it up and you've got
a great freaking drink how many can i
have without getting sloppy well that's
a shot and a half tequila in there
even by one i've got like a just like
the the right buzz you know what i mean
like the right daytime buzz
two i'm okay i think i've done three a
couple times and you know
after you've had three margaritas you
know you're usually uh pretty whacked
um all right let's see uh
sahira says what type of guidelines do
you recommend for people who wish to
join the social media detox but need to
stay plugged in so i totally get it
like as i said we i've got a whole team
of people that
that work for me and who are fantastic
and my guys are all going to be working
and we're going to be
plotting out this new tuesday wednesday
thursday show
and we're we're building out a new
graphics package and a whole bunch of
other stuff
and i guess i have a certain luxury in
that because i've created these
companies and
you know i've hired people that that can
do all this stuff but i understand the
average person can't do this
this month situation that i'm about to
do but i think
referring back to my conversation with
tristan a moment ago
there are little things you can do take
social media off the weekends
everyone can do that like literally
everyone watching this
if you can't do both days for some
reason if you feel like that's too much
there is no reason uh you know you could
do it old school
jewish do saturdays you could do old
school christian do sundays
uh and just take a day off where you're
just not on social media yes
you may be getting texts your phone may
be ringing but i don't think that's
really the thing that's making us all
crazy sometimes a lot of texting
can make you crazy but it's it's the
social media aspect
it's what tristan talked about about the
notifications the constant you're just
sitting there next thing you know trump
said this oh my god next thing you know
oh my god baby picture
terrorist attack sports game like it's
just like a crazy way to ingest news
um you know i always mention this but
back in the old days when i used to fly
on airplanes remember that
um i don't have facebook but i sometimes
if i'm sitting on a plane you know
you're sitting on a plane and someone's
doing something and you just
kind of looking at them you don't even
know why you're doing it it's not like
they're doing anything great
but like you're just looking at what
they're doing they're reading a
newspaper they're looking on their ipad
whatever
and i would see sometimes people
scrolling facebook and because i don't
have facebook i completely have
forgotten what facebook
is but you're watching it and it's like
okay terrorist attack
trump said something baby birthday
crazy meme animal and it's like
can you imagine as you're just scrolling
like the insane
positives negatives joy hate evil
good that's all just like slamming
through you at all times i don't think
that's great to have so take
just a day off just a day off a week if
you can do it
let's see um dave how will you handle
coming back to the grid and discovering
that while you were gone
someone on twitter called you a racist
homophobe
i'll miss those people uh not a day goes
by where someone doesn't call me a
racist homophobe
i'll be okay i'll be okay i've managed
it i've managed it it used to bother me
i'm not gonna say it never bothered me
back
years ago when all this started all this
craziness online
and people would write these articles
about me and i'm far right and i'm
racist
and i'm a homophobe and like the rest of
the knots it's like it used to bother me
and now you know the media has been so
exposed the trolls are just the trolls
that it doesn't bother me anymore it's
like you guys got nothing left you guys
got nothing left and actually if
anything you've done more to red pill
people than than the people that are
talking about sensible things
the more hysterical you guys become so i
will be okay
even if when i return and i open twitter
for the first time
the first thing that i see is dave
you're a racist
homophobe um can
ted cruz be the guest host when you
return or even michael knowles i am not
going to say it
at the moment but i promise it will be
someone
that you like that the reuben report
audience likes
uh lauren do you have more hope clarity
and peace of mind when you come back
from being unplugged yeah
yeah you know when i came back was it
two years ago i don't think it was last
year i think it was two years ago um
was when i came back and i said during
the live stream
that i don't consider myself an atheist
anymore that is not
a coincidence it's it's something that i
had been thinking about for a long time
i
you know i've said this many times and
people get angry when i say it but this
is the truth
i i never there was like a when i
started the show
as an interview show the reuben report
back in the fall of 2015 i had had a
bunch of
well-known atheists on it started
obviously with sam harris and then peter
bogosian and michael shermer
and a couple other people who are
friends and wonderful people
and i had a lot of atheists on and then
i think people just started thinking
that i was an atheist and then i sort of
said it one day
and just sort of like it just kind of
like blurted out but i never felt that
it really um
encompassed exactly what i believe and i
think i even
referenced that i gave a talk at the um
the reason rally which was at the
in washington dc at the the mall you
know like the the place where forrest
gump gave that big talk in front of the
water i spoke there in front of
thousands of people
and i think i even referenced something
to that effect but anyway when i came
back from the grid two years ago
and i had had time to be away and to
think it was just very obvious to me
that i do believe in something else i do
believe
and and this is where you know when
people ask jordan does he believe in god
this is where the conversation can be so
crazy
um and some people believe you have to
have a personal relationship with god
that's more of
a christian belief um you know the the
more jewish belief would be that there's
a sort of grappling with god
um and then there's many other beliefs
around that um but it was very obvious
to me that i do believe in something
outside of myself and i think that that
thing and i write about this in the book
is the thing that we need to organize
functional societies which as i say all
the time is why our founders were so
brilliant because
they said we have god-given rights
meaning you are born free and we're
all we're doing is setting up a
government to protect those god-given
rights
the government didn't give them to you
because then other that means that the
government somehow made you free but the
government didn't
make you free it can take away your
freedom but didn't give it to you anyway
i mentioned that because the fact that i
was able to like
that that thought just kind of
crystallized in my brain
in august of two years ago kind of shows
you that if you give yourself some time
to think
and not be in the mix and the muck all
the time that i think that
i don't know what realization you'll
come to in your life but i think you
will come
to some realizations maybe you'll come
to the other the opposite realization
maybe if you took a month off and you're
a believer right now you'd come to the
realization that
yeah i'm not a believer anymore i mean
who knows who knows but there's probably
only one way to find out
uh let's see rj wants to know
the world wants to know if clyde will
get his own twitter account
well clyde at the moment maybe we'll get
him in here before we uh end the stream
clyde uh you know he had this scar when
we got him
he had this scar on his head and we
thought it was from abuse and then we
were gonna
we decided to get it removed because
every few weeks it started bleeding and
that's obviously not good
and it wasn't it wasn't healing up we
took him to the
uh a special it was actually through a
fan at the reuben report community she
mentioned that her husband
is a as a dermatologist an animal
dermatologist in l.a
so we we took him there a couple weeks
ago he had the thing removed it turns
out that it wasn't a scar
he was born with some sort of like cyst
and there were like a couple tiny ones
anyway he got them all removed
he's been in stitches in a cone for two
weeks he got the stitches out two days
ago
and it's starting to look a lot better
but uh it didn't heal fully yet so he's
still got the freaking cone the poor
guy's been in a cone for like two and a
half weeks
he's he's just had it with the cone uh
but he will be better on the other side
will he have a twitter account
why would i subject my dog to it i all
these celebrities with the dog twitter
accounts it's like you know what i like
dog pics i put a lot of dog pics out
there
but the dog doesn't need a twitter
account wouldn't that be counter
everything else that i'm doing right
here
um all right one more and then i'm going
to bring on michaela peterson
uh chris says how's kyle kashub is he
behaving
well unless you know something about
kyle that i don't know but kyle actually
just started his own podcast and he
launched
his community on locals i think it's
kyle kashuv.locals.com kyle if you're
watching you can confirm that for the
good people
but he's building out a great community
there and i did his podcast i am the
first guest
on his new podcast last night and we
opened up about a ton of stuff he's he
actually is quite a good interviewer
maybe he learned a little something from
me maybe not maybe here to learn not
what to do for me
um but i really enjoyed talking to him
we talked for about an hour and a half
and i think it's going up today
uh and it's kyle kashuv.locals.com and
he's just a great
he's a great young person who i think
has an incredibly bright future and i'm
thrilled that i you know i've been just
like a little piece of
of what has perhaps helped get him there
and
on that note let's bring on michaela
peterson
who is the purveyor of the lion diet and
we're going to talk about the lion diet
and eating meat and all sorts of stuff
michaela how are you good how are you
i'm good i'm good i'm only a few hours
away from disappearing and i can
feel the things starting to bubble up in
me so uh
i wanted to talk to you about diet for
15 or 20 minutes
first off um can i ask where you are i
feel like every time i text you you're
in another country you're doing
something else
what's going on at the moment i am
currently in belgrade in
serbia how's everything in belgrade
these days um it's completely full of
coronavirus
uh but it turns out yeah they let
everybody loose about a month ago for
elections and then
cases skyrocketed um but it's good it's
nice
it's kind of similar to canada weirdly
enough except just full of
central eastern europeans it turns out i
called it eastern europe once and people
got
pissed off it's southern eastern
something like that southern eastern
okay you got to be very careful those
those eastern europeans can be touchy
about that so look i have to ask you but
quickly before
we do anything else is there anything
that you can kind of update people on
with your dad or you
just do you just want to leave it to
that last conversation and then and then
we'll talk diet
uh we're surviving like things could be
better if there's a lot of up and downs
um
but we're all still alive so that's good
that's about all the detail i'm going to
get into that
it's totally fine and as i say to you
all the time send him my love and and
everyone watching this i know is pulling
for him so okay
you know i'm going off the grid um i was
on your podcast a couple weeks ago and
we we talked quite extensively about
diet and i've told you that over the
last
two or three years i had some autoimmune
stuff and
i switched to a mostly paleo very low
carb diet and it
my hair grew back because i had alopecia
areata i still have a couple
little little spots back here uh which
i'm doing some stuff for but i do
mostly kind of meet chicken fish and
veggies
i want you right now to sell me on the
lion diet because i'm gonna have 30 days
and i will commit
to let's say five or seven days at least
of trying it
so so sell it on me and what am i
missing by by not doing lion
well so the idea behind the lion diet so
that's all ruminant meat
is that most disease is caused by gut
damage
and there's a hippocrates quote that
what all disease originates in the gut
something like that so the idea behind
the lion diet is you remove anything
that's
irritating to the gut ruminant meat is
not irritating to the gut
some people react well with eggs too
um you do that for long enough
until your symptoms go away and heal the
leaky gut
and then you introduce foods back in
preferably with
probiotics or fermented foods to
regrow the microbiome that's probably
damaged from antibiotics that
everybody took at some point so the the
all beef diet
isn't like it's dull i mean if you had
to choose one food to eat
then it it would probably be steak but
it's it's dull and if you only do it for
seven days honestly
you're going to get serious cravings and
you're not going to feel
better in seven days from what i've seen
and i've talked to thousands of people
and lots of doctors who use this there
are a number of
russian doctors and hungarian doctors
that use a similar diet
and it's a meat-based diet at the
beginning to heal the gut and then
slowly
incorporating in and you start slow with
like cooked vegetables and fermented
foods
but it does take about six weeks to
get some sort of gut healing to occur if
you do it for about seven days you
basically go into carb withdrawal
and then you stop um the fact that
you've been on a paleo diet is gonna
make it a lot easier to
get into the um like anything that's
similar to an all beef diet
because most people who have a really
hard time come straight from eating like
drinking coke as their liquid and eating
pizza as their main food
and that's pretty nasty to drop all of
those
foods but uh paleo to carnivore
it'll be easier but it's still not
pleasant but the idea behind it is
that allows you to heal the gut and then
you well can start from scratch with
reintroduction
right the idea behind it
right so i don't know that i can do it
for the for the full month because part
of the reason i go off the grid is so
that i can like sort of fully enjoy
foods and and everything else but i but
i have but you know we talked about i
have been sort of incorporating more and
more
tonight i am really like i'm sort of
amazed by it because
when i was on tour with your dad for
that year and a half i mean people
thought it was a joke but i was with him
for breakfast i was with him for lunch i
was with him for dinner
he'd have you know sometimes he would
have the steak cooked the night before
so he could have breakfast and he would
have the steak and everything else
and i saw him physically feel better he
would he would talk about
how his uh his skin looked better and i
was with him and i was like man his skin
really does look better or
his hair look thicker or he would talk
about sometimes like he had some like
gingivitis kind of stuff and his teeth
looked
his teeth looked better so you've seen
like
that what i saw there is that really
what you consistently see with people
that that do this
yeah consistently if people are not
taking medications and they
really just go down to ruminant meat and
sometimes that's a carnivore diet
sometimes they incorporate eggs in as
well
fish if they stick with it for long
enough i haven't seen anybody's symptoms
not improve unless they're still taking
medications
and then sometimes that's enough to
irritate i guess that's enough to
irritate your gut enough to not allow it
to heal
but um the idea isn't that
the idea isn't that you should be stuck
with this forever at least that's not my
opinion i know there are some carnivore
diet
um doctors out there that say you know
this is how people
are supposed to eat and that's it but
i don't i don't think that's true i
think that people thrive on a
largely meat diet um
but if they eat like certain foods
certain vegetables
prepared in an appropriate way then
that's totally fine
right what do you say to the people that
would say well
all right if you did six weeks just meet
before you introduce any of this stuff
that you're not getting certain vitamins
and minerals that you need do you
recommend that people take supplements
or you think that it's just
pure meat for that reset and that's then
when you incorporate that stuff back
that you'll be okay
in essence until you're back on some of
the other stuff yeah
you're going to want to keep it um
higher on the fat ratios
just doing lean meat is not going to
make people feel very good
but i did like steak only steak
for about a year and then i started
incorporating liver in
i've seen some people improve when they
have certain organs
but a lot of those people are vitamin
deficient to begin with
so i'd say testing your vitamins is
useful but you can get all the nutrients
you need
from meat plus organs for some people
um and six weeks is nothing like i
wouldn't worry about that at all
right for the people that just don't
know you or know your story the re you
came to this in a pretty freaking
amazing
situation because you went through as
your dad would put it some pretty brutal
health stuff can you just tell everybody
like what caused you to do this and how
it actually did help you
yeah i'll give like a two-minute
overview um i was diagnosed with
rheumatoid art juvenile rheumatoid
arthritis when i was seven
i had symptoms starting at two i was put
on like a
plethora of drugs um and i still ended
up with my hip and ankle replaced when i
was 17.
i had a mood disorder bipolar type 2
i could barely function because the
brain fog
then i was diagnosed with idiopathic
hypersomnia
and i was just sleeping all the time
exhausted all the time
and then i started getting skin problems
and rashes and it was just like
i got sicker and sicker and sicker and
sicker and at one point
i kind of thought hell i'll just try an
elimination diet just to see what
happens and i came up with my own
elimination diet in 2015 that was just
like
very simplified paleo basically like
meats certain root vegetables um
yeah that was it and i got way better
within a month
um like it really only took a month it
was crazy
and i started a blog
because i honestly kind of thought it
was nuts it was like
i lost a bunch of weight my arthritis
went away three months later my
depression went away
my skin healed um and i thought
why is nobody talking about this because
there weren't as many you know now there
are paleo and keto groups everywhere
but i scoured the internet i couldn't
find anyone else who had the same
experience and mine was pretty severe
like
people don't have joints replaced when
they're a teenager
um but yeah i came to the meat diet
eventually because i got pregnant had a
baby
and i seemed to have lost my tolerance
for the vegetables my autoimmune
disorder came back
even on my very limited paleo diet and i
kind of gave up and thought
okay i know i don't react to beef i'll
just try that
out of desperation and because i
actually like
do like vegetables and fruit um and
i just stuck with it and it was kind of
miserable at the beginning and
six weeks in my depression lifted
lifted five months in my anxiety went
away and it was
maybe a week when my joints started
feeling better like that happened
more quickly so i've been publicizing
that but now
i've found doctors who are actually
using this diet to treat
um so yeah that's a bit of my background
and it started
started sounding crazy because
newspapers were coming out saying
you know beef girl says beef heals
everything
but the actual idea is
that disease is a lot of diseases caused
by leaky gut and
if you eliminate everything other than
like animal protein and fat that seems
to heal leaky gut
and then you should be able to
reintroduce and i haven't told anybody
yet
but i reintroduced like apples
which used to give me serious autoimmune
problems
and i've had no problems so far i'm
seem to be more tolerant than i was
prior to the diet
so the whole leaky gut theory and being
able to heal and being able to vary your
diet
seems to actually be working fingers
crossed
wow that's incredible yeah no and i've
i've seen it firsthand and i remember
when i was on tour with your dad and he
was talking about some of the stuff you
were going through and i remember
hearing you say
that you were getting better and all
this stuff i realized that as you were
telling me that i took a sip
of coffee black coffee are you telling
me i cannot have black coffee because
that
i could get rid of i have no problem i
don't eat donuts like i don't care about
the sugary stuff i really don't i can
get rid of the bread
yeah i'd miss i'd miss a slice of pizza
every couple weeks
but like coffee come on can i have some
coffee
it's really like it depends it depends
on you
you'll know like if people stick with
this for long enough i
i i know of people whose problems didn't
go away
just because they were drinking coffee
sticking to the diet just drinking
coffee and as soon as i got rid of the
coffee
whatever issue they had went away
um so yeah i would say ditch the coffee
but it also depends how sensitive you
are
like alopecia means you have some sort
of inflammatory
problem but you don't have like
full-blown autoimmunity
like for those people i'd say just ditch
the coffee until you feel better
um but then you're gonna go through
caffeine withdrawal so that that would
suck
that would suck indeed what what about
where does booze fit into this because
you know some of my best nights with
your dad although he was
just doing the beef thing every now and
again we'd go out for dinner after
sometimes with a group sometimes just us
and your mom and and he'd have a whiskey
and i know how much he enjoyed it the
guy he wasn't getting drunk but just to
be able to sit there and have something
else
where does booze fit into this so and i
this makes the entire thing
sound less credible but
i didn't really have an issue with
bourbon and vodka and those are both uh
distilled from grain
but they're distilled so there's no
grain left they don't add anything
after the distillation unlike
gin scotch like those all have things
added in after
they made me feel terrible on a zero
carb diet hangovers are
way worse but um i seem to have healed
keeping alcohol i eliminated it for the
first maybe nine months
um because i just needed to get my
autoimmune symptoms under control
but then i i can manage to drink alcohol
specifically vodka and bourbon so i
would say that's actually probably
less irritating because there's no plant
compounds left than coffee
yeah so it sounds like a lot of this is
a little just trial for everybody that
you have to kind of see how your system
reacts to some of this stuff which i
guess makes it kind of weird but it's
sort of empowering at the same time
i mean some people have to go down to
all beef and they have to stick with
that for like a year
you know if you have multiple sclerosis
or something or me
took me a while um but other people can
just go down to
paleo and see exactly the same results
so it seems like if you eliminate like
the main goal is eliminate processed
foods grains
legumes you know sugar eliminate that
seriously inflammatory foods and some
people are fine with that but if you're
already seeing health problems if you're
older uh sometimes you have to be more
strict
but i think you can heal after that you
just have to give your body that ability
to heal
and then you can start bugging it again
with certain things and it has more of a
tolerance
all right michaela well since i read 12
rules for life and
and lived it for a long time i'm not
going to lie to you and say that i'm
going all beef this month but i am going
to incorporate some of this stuff for
sure
and i know that plenty of people that
are watching this will do as well uh
where can we where can we send people
to find out more i've got
okay so i have my website
michaelapeterson.com
um i'm michaela peterson on instagram
michaelalexus on twitter
and my facebook groups actually have a
lot of information and that's
don't eat that and the lion diet
[Music]
all right awesome well thanks so much
for doing this and of course
send my love to your dad and to your mom
and everybody else and uh i'll talk to
you in september
thank you have a good month all right
thanks you too
all right so there we go i will
incorporate i didn't realize that
actually what she said that the seven
day thing really
won't do that much i may try to do some
version of that anyway because it's sort
of just like a hyper paleo thing
um but i'm not having like all sorts of
issues but for those of you that aren't
sure what i was referencing
i i talk about in the book and i've
mentioned it on a couple live streams
a couple years ago i developed this
autoimmune disease called alopecia
areata which
all they can chalk it up to is stress i
had all my blood done and all the tests
and i was fine otherwise
but i lost huge huge chunks of hair
mostly in the back of my head side over
here
there were episodes in my show where we
were literally spraying on my hair and
painting the back of my head and it was
horrible and i went on this
crazy experimental medication and this
is just as my career was taking off and
i really thought about quitting for a
while i actually
there was a day where i was like done i
really was done again it's in the book
um and then i did start changing my diet
as as part of this
because it's an autoimmune disease it's
a it's an inflammatory
situation and i started eating foods
that were less inflammatory or
anti-inflammatory foods
and and i have solved most of it but i
do i do still have two or three like
little
ones almost like a i got like two or
three like dime-sized
spots on my head that don't apparent i
do something called uh
it's called plasma plate plasma rich
therapy
class prp plasma rich
plasma prp someone tell me what prp
stands for but in essence
uh every other month they take my blood
they spin it in a centrifuge the blood
separates and then they inject
the plasma my own plasma back into my
head like into those spots and that
helps regrow hair
it has it hasn't been absolutely
platelet-rich plasma thank you very much
voice of god that appeared in my ear
platelet-rich plasma
and they can do that in something called
microneedling which i do so i do one
month of platelet-rich plasma
and then i take a month off and i do
microneedling which is they take
in essence a electronic needle and they
just
ding you in the head like a gajillion
times it does not feel good i assure you
of that
when i do the platelet-rich plasma
because it's a bigger needle
i get some of the happy gas which the
first few times i really liked like
you're kind of like just lost in la la
land you don't even know what you're
saying and my
doctor would always be like dude you're
saying some crazy stuff
but you kind of whatever now i don't
like it anymore something happened where
it was like
i don't know i went from like enjoying
it where now i'm like i'd rather deal
with the pain
than that um but a few of you have met
reached out to me
over the last couple of months and
mentioned that you've been uh dealing
with some
uh inflammatory stuff yourself and some
of you have talked about
alopecia and all sorts of stuff and i
basically have it under control right
now so that is
good um okay
let me jump yeah so i'm going to jump
back to some questions again if you want
to submit some questions you can go to
reubenreport.com or you can download our
ios
or google android app just search ruben
report or you can just download the
locals app which has
all the people that are on locals and
it's growing and growing and growing we
have so much good stuff going on with
locals right now it's crazy
uh but scott adams is on there carl and
borsenko's on there bridge of fed as
he's on there zooby's on there
kyle kashub's on there michael malus is
on there we got a whole bunch of groups
that have nothing to do with me the the
platform itself
right now it's coming from my world
because you know i'm one of the
co-founders of the company
but even if you're one of the political
people that hate me if you want to build
a digital home where you own all your
stuff and you can make money and it has
nothing to do with me we're just giving
you the tools
and you want to make a community called
dave rubin's an idiot go ahead feel free
to monetize it my pleasure
and uh and it's not just politics gamers
unboxers knitters whatever the
whatever the hell you might be um
heavy metal homo says what are the
general rules for being off the grid
i mean i think everyone can kind of do
it their own way i'm obviously doing
something extremely
aggressive and uh intense by by shutting
it down
all together but whatever it means to
you you know it's not that you can't
walk around without a phone i mean
there's security reasons you might want
to have a phone and staying connected
with family and the rest of it
but i think the social media component
is the part so
as i said before if you could take a
saturday off or a sunday or maybe both
or maybe one week in august maybe the
last week in august just take the week
off
some version of that maybe try not to
check emails on weekends
you know like i think you have to figure
sort of like what michaela was just
saying about the diet you have to figure
out something that works for you um
there's something about this like very
extreme measure
that i've really come to love and
appreciate and the fact that so many
people are so interested
uh when i'm doing it it's it's kind of
amazing and it shows that maybe i'm onto
something here
but you got to figure out some rules
that work for you these
all the people that i'm reading
questions from by the way are in the
reuben report community and it's like if
the entire
internet was in essence what we've built
there and what we'll continue to add
features to and build there which was
just sort of goodness and not overloaded
with insanity
and pleasant people sharing pleasant
things then i think we would all sort of
need this less but that's just not
reality as it is we're building our own
sort of alternate reality over there
which is
which is pretty good um let's see
chris says are we kooky conspiracy
theorists for thinking that excessive
quarantines and attacks on federal
courthouses
are election-year political maneuvers i
mean we're all conspiracy
theorists these days like the media has
been so decimated journalism has been so
destroyed
our institutions have been so rotted out
that if you're not
a conspiracy theorist at some level if
you're just accepting whatever the
mainstream
narrative is if you're just getting the
new york times to your doorstep and
reading it and being like well now i got
the truth
or you're watching don lemon
as tucker carlson calls him or whatever
you're getting on cnn and thinking oh
that's giving you unbiased news that
that's just crazy
so it's funny because the terms
conspiracy theorists like that somehow
as you believe
in ancient aliens and you believe that
in
jfk assassination theories and all this
other stuff
i don't think that's really what people
mean by conspiracy theory anymore if you
just sort of don't accept
the mainstream narrative then almost
everything's a conspiracy and i don't
think there's a lot of reason to
accept the mainstream narrative that
it's a sort of dangerous place to be in
um but i would say that it partly feels
at some level that these rolling
lockdowns remember we were told 15 days
to flatten the curve and then everything
will be back to normal and you can find
videos
of me saying back in june if not may
when i was saying that when there was
this rumor that in california they were
going to close us down till august first
and i kept saying
well the problem here is that i
guarantee you by the end of july last
couple days of july they're going to
tell us this is rolling into august and
congratulations
we're in the last day of july and it's
rolling into august we know that
suddenly in september they're going to
tell us it's the fall
and now because of the weather change
it's sparking again and we see now
teachers unions saying teachers won't
teach in classrooms and this morning i
saw teachers in l.a saying they won't
even teach
on skype so there are that's not to say
it's all some grand conspiracy with some
guy
pulling the strings but like all of the
weirdness
all of the inconsistencies they all do
add up to something and when you factor
in the fact
that we have an election coming and
although it's hard to remember
you know right before coronavirus hit
everything in the country was going
really really well
trump did not have us going to other
wars right we were ending wars
um the economy was going great black
unemployment was at an all-time low
like there were so many good markers and
then now this thing has been injected
into the system
and we can debate whether the policies
and the lockdowns and the quarantines
have all been right and all that
but i don't think it's a conspiracy
theory to say that democrat-run cities
and states
are in some ways trying to destroy
themselves
knowing that the federal government will
have to bail them out and somehow that
will reflect poorly on trump
the look at portland like these riots
now this is half coronavirus half
uh blm antifa stuff but like these riots
like portland decided that the police
could not defend federal buildings that
portland could not defend their own
stores and their own citizens
and then you know the national guard had
to be called in and then it did clean it
up but then you watch democratic
politicians say trump's sending his
soldiers in
and it's like well why didn't you guys
protect your citizens
and and your property because in a way
they don't want to
because this is where and i mean without
sounding like i'm
beating a dead horse progressive sound
nice
they sound nice and all of their
policies in
every single way end up hurting the very
people they purport to be helping
and i think people are waking up to it
and
there's a lot of things that feel like
conspiracy theories that i don't think
are that conspiratorial anymore
um torrid asks you usually go on a trip
in august
um any destinations this year as i said
we're just we're just hunkering down at
home we'll have we'll have some people
come over and visit and
uh but that that's it we're just you
know i guess we could have tried
we may do like a like a weekend trip
maybe just drive up to sonoma
or santa barbara or something like that
but we're not we're not doing major
stuff
um jeff says will you interview a
democrat on the reuben report soon well
look i've had plenty of democrats on
i've had tulsi gabbardon and andrew yang
and mary anne williamson
uh look i would be more than happy i've
gone after them on twitter
so i don't know that they want to talk
to me but i would gladly talk to aoc i
would gladly talk to bernie i would
gladly talk to kamala harris
by the way even though sometimes i'll go
after them on twitter we have
gone through all of the back channels
for a long time to respectfully get
these people on
they do all sorts of other lefty shows
but they don't really want to talk to
people that they disagree with um
but i would i would have nancy pelosi on
of course i would love to find
and someone please point out this person
if they exist if there is a mainstream
democrat
uh that is willing uh to to especially
to talk about what is happening
with the progressive psychosis that is
destroying their party
i would absolutely love to talk to them
but i'll talk to the progressives too
um what can people do this is from
elijah what can people do in the face of
cancer culture there is only
one thing you can do and it is say what
you believe i know it sucks and i know
it sounds kind of cliche
but there's no calvary coming i think
everyone's waiting for the calvary to
come and save everybody they ain't
coming you're the calvary
you've got to stand up for what you
believe
if you don't that gives oxygen to the
bad guys to keep coming
cancel culture preys on the fact that
most of us are just decent people
who want to live and let live and they
and because of that they feel that they
can keep encroaching
and and they'll keep squeezing and
squeezing and squeezing and in many ways
the
the liberals were the guiltiest party
here and that's hard for me to admit but
i think it's true
all the academic liberals who watched
all of the conservatives get canceled
and de-platformed and attacked and
called racists and bigots all these
years
from usually unjust reasons well now
they see it turning on them this is sort
of what that harper's letter was about
and they see it turning on them and
suddenly they're realizing that you
can't
feed this alligator because this
alligator never gets full
and we can keep throwing people under
the bus and there were several people on
that letter who have tried to destroy me
because
people have written articles ruben goes
on tucker carlson and he shared a donald
trump jr tweet
he you know in essence he must be
destroyed he's a bad guy for doing that
they thought they could feed enough
people to the alligator and the
alligator would just be like oh i'm done
eating i'm moving along
the alligator is now encroaching the
land that they sit on so
i am glad that some of the liberals are
waking up barry weiss obviously has
woken up
um matt taibbi like a couple of these
people uh andrew sullivan
like they're waking up but like you know
they're just saying the stuff that i
said
five years ago and you know barry weiss
specifically and i don't mean this as a
personal attack in any way
but the day after the intellectual dark
web piece came out in new york times
she called me crying basically
apologizing that the editor took out the
nice stuff about me and they just had to
throw somebody under the bus in the
article because it couldn't be a
a love fest and then i was out to dinner
with her a few weeks later
david reminded me of this a couple days
ago or a couple weeks ago actually when
she resigned from the new york times but
we were out to dinner and i went to the
bathroom and david told me how she told
him
how sorry she was about the article well
it's like barry why don't you admit that
publicly
admit how the editors manipulated you
publicly because otherwise you're still
sort of throwing me under the bus i
don't mean to make this about me but i
think you get my point it's like the new
york times has been up to this bad stuff
for a really really long time and i
think the liberals
the irony is that this is this is the
split the split is
you're a liberal you're a decent
old-school liberal all right you think
you can fix that thing i talk about this
all the time you think you can fix
what's going on with the progressives
i've never seen any evidence of it
they never stop the social justice
ideology is a
is a mind virus that destroys everything
but if you think you can fix that
congratulations and good for you and go
for it
what i think is that conservatives have
proven themselves to be decent
usually nicer happier people and i would
rather build some bridges that way with
people that i have some political
disagreements with who cares
okay teddy says does david janet keep up
to date on news
uh and is he totally off the grid no as
i said before he will take some pictures
and behind the scenes things of me
preferably when i'm not watching i'm not
going to be smiling at the camera
but maybe about what we're eating and
some of the activities that we're doing
and stuff like that and we will post
them on the reuben report community so
you'll see them there but he's going to
do his own
slight version of off the grid but he
also is the um
executive producer of the show and
manages of all of our employees so he
has some other things to do in the midst
of
all of this uh chris says can you
explain what shadow banning is for those
of us who don't know yeah shadow banning
it's mostly thought of as a twitter
feature not a bug but a feature
uh this in essence is that when you
follow people on twitter
um what you what we all expected when we
got on twitter was that let's say you
follow 10 people on twitter you expect
your feed
to be chronologically what these people
are tweeting out and not
removing some tweets occasionally or
somehow people being missing from your
feed you think i follow 10 people
i'm going to see all of their stuff in
my feed shadow banning is when the
algorithm
decides to just remove certain people or
remove certain tweets or suppress
certain tweets
or make sure that certain tweets don't
get a certain amount of retweets or
likes
or anything like that now we know i keep
telling people about this it's in the
terms of service
in the twitter terms of service it talks
about how they
can uh they can boost i don't remember
the exact
language that they use but that in
essence they can make sure
more things are seen and some things
aren't seen so that is shadow banning
it's called shadow banning because you
don't know it's happening to you
and we see this all the time like if i
tweet about locals or even this morning
when i tweeted about the live stream
it got very very few retweets but i
could literally tweet out a picture
i mean i tested this the other day so
the other day there was a
a trend on twitter that was what was the
trend on twitter
michael help me out here there was a
trend on twitter
something maybe it was about impeachment
or oh or
people turning against trump or or
something like that and i was like
that phrase seems very odd that it's
trending and i looked and apparently
there was a bloomberg article
that had this phrase i can't remember
exactly what it was it's been a busy
couple days
but i saw i looked at it and it was like
it had like 300 retweets and i was like
there's no way that phrase could be
trending because of that and i quickly i
checked and it was like there's nobody
tweeting about this so i tweeted that
out and then i said you know what i bet
i could post a picture of alph and a
poop emoji
and it will get more retweets than that
and my picture of alf in a poop emoji
got something like three thousand
retweets and 10 000 likes but that
didn't trend
now all this is without getting too
insider baseball it just shows you that
they are messing around with us
uh in ways that are unimaginable and
that's what these congressional hearings
are about and i suspect that that's
going to continue to be
some of the hot topics like i think i'm
going to miss a lot related to all of
that
but in essence shadow banning is when
they're not showing you the stuff that
you signed up
to show for um
let's see a whole bunch of you were
asking me i see the crazy ears is asking
us and a couple other people
also asked something along the lines
like what kind of event would it take
you to break
um break your digital quarantine um
so again i i have i have four things
that i wrote out that could bring me
back
that aren't all public things i mean
some of them are personal things
um i hope that i don't have to come back
um
but you know if there's some like true
horrific incident that
could severely affect my life or the
life of people that i love or something
like that
like then we'll see what happens um but
you know if
it's just like bad news like bad stuff
is happening you know and it's just bad
news like
that's the point of me taking the break
in the first place so if you know some
bad stuff's going on and
as minneapolis is burning again it's
like i don't need to come back for that
that's partly why i'm going off in the
first place
um okay let's see uh jay asks what's the
next phase of locals can you give us a
look into the future updates editions
innovations your wish list
so we're going to have live video
streaming uh soon enough we're going to
have some sort of extra features related
to donations so that if you don't want
to do monthly things i think we're going
to add some of that or
or perhaps you're going to still do
monthly and then you can dole out uh
tips and things differently we just
added if you doubt if you update
yourlocals.com app so just if you don't
have the app just go to
the app store and search locals.com we
now have an unmanipulated feed
so whoever you follow you now get an
aggregated feed the way twitter was
supposed to be of all of those people
so we just added that in the last day or
two people have been asking us
about that we're working on a whole
bunch of feature sets you know this has
been a whole other experience
for me because in the midst of the last
year i started a tech company and i had
to raise funds for that and everything
else
i think this is going to be a huge year
for us i don't know if you guys saw this
yesterday but patreon lost a fairly
major lawsuit
that could in in essence really cause
massive massive problems for the
for the platform i don't think patreon
is the right set of answers anyway
patreon is just a crowd funding place
um that's it no one uses community
features there but in essence what
locals is doing is building you
actual communities it's sort of building
your own fan club
um and uh and we've got a lot of great
stuff coming so uh i can't i can't
relate it all i can't say to oh thank
you for this michael
in the twitter terms of service um
because i want to get back to the shadow
banning thing this is exactly what it
says in the twitter
terms of service we may also
remo remove or refuse to distribute
any content on these services limit
distribution or visibility of
any content on this service suspend or
terminate users and
reclaim usernames without liability to
you
let me reread the important part again
limit distribution or visibility of
any content on the service now really
think about what that means
that means that if twitter so chooses
let's say that twitter's probably not a
huge fan of donald trump
now let's say the president of the
united states tweets something
what if they only show it to half of his
followers
what if they or i mean there's so many
sort of twisted ways they could do this
what if they say okay we'll show it to
all of his followers but when his
followers retweet it
we're only going to show it to 10 of the
people they retweeted to i mean we could
extrapolate a million ways
that they could manipulate you with that
so that
twitter believe it or not people shadow
banning is
in the terms of service one of the
things i keep saying on twitter
is that we're all playing a rigged game
and pretending it isn't rigged i mean
we're basically
the harlem globetrotters versus the
washington generals and we're pr
playing as if we're all watching the
game as if we don't know who's going to
win
in the end the generals did win once i
think it was accidental but you pretty
much know who's going to win and it
ain't the generals
okay let's see a lot of people asking me
if i'm traveling but again not not
traveling
please let it be jordan peterson who
brings you back that would be
spectacular michaela just checked in
they'll they'll hopefully have some more
updates
and it will be great to have jordan back
i i i
can't really say that enough i can't
really say that enough oh
uh well here's a couple good ones um
peter says who do you think will be joe
biden's running mate so that is one of
the big pieces of news i will miss
because he
most certainly will announce this in
august i'm hearing it come as early as
next week you know there was this
political article where they
accidentally leaked
that it's going to be kamala harris and
they even had a statement about her from
joe biden now
is that an actual leak was it a planted
leak to see how the
people would react or how the meteor act
i just i
really think kamala harris is awful i
think she's the worst sort of
authoritarian and i don't think she
believes in the constitution and i've
talked about that many times before i
don't think it will be her so i'll make
a
prediction maybe i'll be right maybe
i'll be wrong we shall see
um i have a feeling
that it will not be someone who ran in
the primaries now first off
we know he's going with a woman he has
said that a million times so could he
possibly back out of that i think he'd
probably regret
saying it but i don't see how he can
back out of it right and he's an old
white man so he's evil by
his own party's ideology uh so he's
saying it has to be a woman now
so you could take a couple of the women
that were in the primary so that leaves
you with kamala
elizabeth warren um klobuchar
tulsi although they really just tried to
kick her out am i forgetting any other
women there
there another woman i might be
forgetting i think i think those are the
big ones
um i don't think it'll be elizabeth
warren because there's too much of a
rivalry with her and bernie and the
bernie people are going to burn down the
whole thing either way i mean everyone
that's rioting right now and taking down
statues they're all bernie supporters
bernie bernie brought this thing out
this is all bernie's fault
uh he was screaming for years how evil
america is and how racist we are and how
he wants a political revolution but what
he really meant was he wants a regular
revolution
and a regular revolution is violent he
only said political
every revolution is political the french
revolution was political the american
revolution is political but he didn't
want to say revolution
because people know that comes with
heads on spikes and things like that
so bernie has brought this thing forth
anyway i don't think it's going to be
any of the women that ran i think he
will go
outside for some like unknown excitement
could it be michelle obama i think
anything is freaking
possible i think this is what i will say
whatever happens
related to the democratic vp nothing
will surprise me there will be no way i
could be surprised
when i sit back down on september 1st
and my guest host tells me who it is
nothing could surprise me you could tell
me that biden dropped out
and announced that he has you know
dementia or some other cognitive problem
or has some other health problem or just
doesn't want to do it or has a back ache
or whatever that wouldn't surprise me if
then they smuggle in somebody else it
wouldn't surprise me
if it's michelle obama it wouldn't
nothing would surprise me because the
whole thing is so
fixed and so corrupt and the dnc is so
deeply deeply corrupt and even right now
watching
watching biden like basically take
bernie's platform if you're if you i
don't know how if you are
if you are a lifelong moderate democrat
which most
people in the democratic party were for
a long time
you're watching your whole thing be
destroyed and that's why i think most of
those people are going to end up voting
for trump it's just not going to show up
in the polls
but an average democrat's going to go
well
this thing is insane this thing is
completely bananas
you know maybe i don't like the way
trump speaks and he is orange
but at least he likes america um and i
think
i think that will not show up in the
polls but nothing will surprise me it's
very possible joe biden will not be the
nominee i don't think they're going to
let him debate
i mean i i think they tried to smuggle
biden in
they coalesced around biden because they
thought that was the tolerable one to
the electorate
because their own electorate isn't as
radical as as the party is or whatever
as the machinery is
and they didn't realize that biden was
going to break down this quickly um but
it's it's obvious to everyone as i keep
saying
the scandal is the non-scandal the
scandal is not that biden has
dementia or whatever it is the scandal
is that no one will talk about it right
all day uh almost every day i tweet
something about why doesn't can
can any democrat any blue check democrat
politician or pundit will anyone go on
the record saying they don't think
there's anything wrong with him
cognitively and no one will do it
no one will do it because they all know
something's wrong with him and the
second it leaks
which it will leak at some point he may
be president at that point then we've
got a
much bigger problem but the second it
leaks they're all going to say oh i knew
it too i wanted to say something but the
party apparatus wouldn't let me the dnc
wouldn't let me
they stopped me from saying something
but i was the good guy it's coming out
guys
you guys created the monster and now you
got to figure out what to do with the
monster so
nothing will surprise me biden may not
be the nominee michelle obama may be the
nominee she could be the backup
you could who the freak knows like it
really it's so
bananas that who the hell knows but my
my real gut feeling is it will not be
one of the women assuming biden is the
nominee it will not be one of the women
that was in the nomination process it
will not be one of the female democratic
candidates that were in that
i think probably he he ends up choosing
a black female
just because they've they've played the
intersectional game for so long
that if he doesn't pick a black one
let's say he just picks a woman a
totally qualified woman whatever that is
and she happens to be white
well the base will burn them down right
how could you not choose a black person
so he's gonna have to do that
that seems kind of obvious i suppose um
but then he does that and then who who
is that person who are those you know is
there
uh a more moderate black democrat female
i mean just think about the way i'm
talking about this it's so stupid
lordy lordy um okay how long have we
been going we've been doing what about
an hour 15 i'll do about 15 more and
then
i will send one last twitter thread off
with a couple
thoughts sort of encapsulating some of
what i've been talking about here and
then i have a whole bunch of work to do
with my guys to get everybody set up for
the month
and uh and then that will be it people i
will stop
looking at things which would be nice my
eyes are burning for this screen is very
bright who looks at this stuff all day
um give me your top five for who will be
canceled by the time you get back that's
funny
uh who will be canceled by the time i
get back well
i'll talk about it broadly which is you
know one of the things i've been trying
to explain
to my lefty friends is that you guys can
complain that the conservatives are evil
and hate all of you but who's gonna
destroy
ellen degeneres one day you know ellen's
under a lot of fire right now because of
uh some workplace harassment or
something going on at the at the
production company
it's the left that is going to take out
ellen degeneres
who's going to take out jimmy kimmel for
the black face and everything else it's
the
left that's going to take out jimmy
kimmel who will ultimately i even said
this to bill maher's face once i've met
him a couple times i said to bill the
first time i met him
i said bill um you know you got to watch
out for the left
and i wish i could do a better bill
maher impression but he looked at me and
he was like
i got the left who's going to take out
bill maher one day it's going to be the
left
who's going to burn down harvard it's
going to be the left
are there trump supporters rallying
right now and destroying universities
and destroying federal buildings and
burning things down
we do have a series of deeply
disingenuous democratic politicians
who are saying well wait a minute why
didn't the feds come in when all of
those
protesters were at the capitol building
in michigan remember when all of the
they were sort of tea party-ish people
were showing at the capitol building
against the lockdown in michigan
and people saying well why weren't the
feds sent there it's because they were
mostly white
uh uh brainiacs nobody was violent
there was literally no violence they had
guns some of them they had open carry
but there was no violence remember the
original tea party what didn't they have
violence and yet the media was
completely against them and now the
media is somehow
for i mean did you hear barack obama's
speech he gave a political rally speech
at john lewis funeral which seemed a
little odd to me
but in essence he was saying we're
sending in troops against peaceful
protesters
there would have been no need for troops
if if the mayor of portland
or seattle would have done their job so
uh
who will be canceled i think well i
think what will happen is
and what i'm more concerned about i've
been saying this for years
is that people will just keep
self-selecting out of the system i think
the day of celebrity in a in a
traditional way and maybe this is a good
thing
i think the day of celebrity is sort of
ending nobody really cares what
celebrities think anymore we've been
locked in our houses
you care about your family and your
friends but the idea that because a
celebrity says something it means
anything and it's usually a celebrity
that has armed guards and has
giant fences and tells you how horrible
you are i think their day is over
i will also say related to this you know
um that the nba is back and i'm a huge
basketball fan i love basketball i got a
basketball there i got basketballs all
over my house
um i i'm not watching the nba this year
i'm not calling for a boycott
i'm not calling for anyone to be
canceled or taken out
but they've put black lives matter on
their court black lives matter is a
political organization that is a
self-described marxist organization that
wants to destroy the nuclear family
amongst a bunch of other terrible stuff
i have no need to support that so what
do i do the same thing i've been doing
for five years
when i do cardio i open up youtube and i
watch old 80s and 90s
basketball games and i guarantee you
what you will see with magic and bird
and michael and clyde and everybody else
and barkley and ewing and
carl malone and john stockton and i
could name the rest of the freaking
league in those years
uh it's way more entertaining and less
political
than what you're getting these days so
they're just not going to get my support
they're not i mean
i guess at the game last night everybody
including the referees
kneeled for the national anthem like do
you guys know how good you have it
in this freaking spectacularly amazing
unique incredible country called the
united states of america
um i saw an old navy commercial have any
of you seen this this old navy
commercial
uh with with black lives matter and you
know we've all got to unite and
diversity in the rainbow but they don't
even use a regular rainbow flag now
we've got the black and brown strip on
it the rainbow flag used to have nothing
to do with race
now we've injected race into the rainbow
flag nope there was not a gay person
wandering around that thought that the
rainbow flag didn't include everybody
right it included everybody the colors
of the rainbow but now we've injected
color and race into the rainbow flags so
they showed that rainbow flag with the
black and brown
and then they showed the black lives
matter thing it's like i don't buy old
navy clothes anyway i guess i did back
in the day
i don't need those big jeans but like
why would i support this company
sprite's got a commercial running around
they're i guess giving money to black
lives matter or something's like i don't
drink spider anyway if i want high
fructose corn syrup i'll drink it
straight out of the bottle
um but i'm not gonna do that like and i
think that's what the future of all this
is i don't need to
um i don't need to convince people to to
do all these things and boycotts and
destroy everybody but i think we
i think what will happen actually is
that we will
we will basically see a split in the
country that will not you know i think
people are sort of worried there's going
to be a civil war or red states for blue
states
i think certain people will say you know
what i don't want to support certain
things anymore and people will just this
is an unfortunate reality because
everything's become political
we will just start supporting things
that we feel are aligned with us more
and not supporting other things and
maybe that does lead to what shapiro
describes in his new book
as a further disintegration of the
machine but i think that's kind of where
we're at all right i have been talking
for two hours people i got a long day
ahead of me
uh i am fully caffeinated although i
have not eaten anything today i should
probably have some beef
um but yeah this is it this is
the last stuff that i will do uh here in
this studio it has been an amazing run
we've had and what we're building out
next is going to be even better and
as i said we're going to do live
interviews in a completely live in
person interviews in a completely
different way in a way that i think
nobody's really doing them right now
that i think is going to be
incredibly cool i want to thank all of
you i sort of view this moment as this
is the end of my season i always view
the sort of end of july last day of july
is the end of the season
then we got our break our summer break
and then we start a new season
in september so we started the interview
version of the reuben report in
september of 2005
2005. geez 2015
i haven't been doing it for that long um
so we will start the new season
in in september uh i just want to thank
you guys for being on the
the adventure with me i mean this year
of all years i mean not only because of
corona
and because of the the riots and the
protests and a book launch in the middle
of this
i'll tell you something i know you guys
aren't going to believe me but i swear
to god this is true i have not seen my
book in a store
we've sold thousands and thousands and
thousands of copies
new york times bestseller as corrupt as
that thing is every amazon number one on
all the appropriate charts
i haven't even seen my book in a store
because i just don't even go to stores
anymore at this point like
that that i or even in an airport i kept
thinking when i was writing the book i
was like how cool would it be i travel
so much i'm going to see it in all these
different airports different cities
i haven't even seen my book in a store
it's a weird thing but there's been a
there's been a bananas year for
everybody
and my team has grown here um so i
should give thanks
to to all of my guys to matt and michael
and david and helen and
phoenix and talia and i'm sure i'm going
to forget people and i apologize for
doing that but everybody that works with
us and a sophomore at locals
and just everybody and the entire locals
team who's been amazing like i
started a tech company in the midst of
all this um
so all right i think i've been talking
enough
for one day as i said if you want to
sort of track what i'll be doing
although i won't be doing it myself
you can join us at reubenreport.com
and uh just have a great summer i hope
you incorporate some of the things that
i talked about here into your life if
you feel that they're
needed or worthwhile and uh
that's it for me there will be one
twitter thread and when i see in
september it'll be in an all new
all new location um and all new stuff
coming
and i'm getting all kinds of sentimental
on here right now geez well thanks
everybody that's it i got nothing left
thank you and i'll see you when i see
you
[Music]